I actually want to segue into our next
topic here which is a really interesting
re-re SL investigation that Hardware
unboxed and Hardware canox have done
with Intel's Arc b580 finding that oh
somebody just collapsed a topic uh
finding that it
has a complicated performance profile
depending on what you bench it with so
while making a video about the arcb 580
Hardware Canucks ran into problems when
pairing the Intel G pu with older
Hardware they tested on an i5 9600k on a
z390 motherboard with resizable bar on
Now intel has been completely upfront
that resizable bar is a NE is necessary
we were like you know hey how much
performance uplift down lift whatever
and they're like doesn't matter turn it
on turn it on it's basically from our
point of view the minimum system
requirements are you have rebar period
okay okay all right fair enough in many
games
performance seems to be on par with the
competition but in other games the b580
struggled to keep up with even a GTX
1660 super and this is a card that
performed a breast with a 4060 even
sometimes a 4060 TI in our review an
important note by the way Intel Arc does
not officially support 9th gen Intel
CPUs and 300 series chipsets even if
they have rebar these are 6 to 7even
years old
um with with 15th gen chips uh releasing
in October of 2024 so that that's that's
important to note but intel only
explicitly ever said hey um you got to
have rebar um they didn't they never
really said okay you can't I official
support okay well whatever take it for
what it is official support okay well
what about AMD hard run box did some
testing they found that officially
supported AMD CPUs like the ryzen 55600
and the 3000 Series also saw significant
drop offs in perform performance Arc
seems to have more CPU overhead whether
it's in its drivers or I guess it would
have to be it drivers compared to other
cards so as you go down in generation
and down in the product stack to older
less performant CPUs graphics
performance is seriously impacted in
games that are especially already CPU
intensive lower frame rates like when
running in 1440p are less impacted than
higher FPS 1080p results which makes
sense because 1440p with you know Medi
or high details is going to be a lot
more GPU bound and a lot less CPU bound
Hardware on box put up a more extensive
review today this says today but when
were these notes written whatever
recently with some interesting results
so go check those out when we're done
here both hardware conu and Hardware
unboxed report that Intel is aware of
their findings and is currently looking
into the matter
um I mean here's a disc it was it was
today 16 hours ago discussion question
how many generations of CPUs and
chipsets should we reasonably expect a
GPU maker to support and I think that's
a complicated answer because in the case
of something like a
5090 I wouldn't even think that it was
that outlandish if Nvidia came out and
said yep here's the 5090 it's
$2,000 um we're offering official
support for ryzen 7000 ryzen 9000 and
Intel 13th J and up because
realistically the vast majority of
people buying this thing are either
buying it in a brand new system don't
underestimate how many people are buying
gpus in full systems that the like
discreet individual GPU
Market you don't matter I won't say who
straight up because I don't know if this
is private or not I was talking to an SI
while I was at the event they said
they've never had this many pre-orders
and they did genuinely zero marketing to
the point where they almost hit it
they've never had this many pre-orders
don't underestimate it and then number
two option is they're putting it into a
system
that is probably pretty new if you have
$2,000 to spend on a GPU you have a
freaking ton of money to spend on you
know not a GPU yeah um unless you're
crazy in which case I mean you do
you however I'm going to offer an
alternative take on that if you are
pitching your card as a as a value card
it's 250 bucks I think if you come out
and say yeah we support this generation
and the last generation you're going to
get laughed out of the room much like
Intel did with Alchemist because it was
an even bigger problem then to only
support rebar platforms because rebar
was a relatively new innovation or was
relatively new at least to Consumer
platforms and so with with b580 coming
in essentially requiring not only rebar
which I think would have been fine at
this point because that takes you back
like at least five years how far how far
back do we have to go for rebar I think
about five years um so that takes you
back a good number of years not just
that but requiring a recent platform I
think really harms the value proposition
of the
card
so I guess we'll see how this plays out
I mean I'm trying to think back I forget
whether it was AMD or Nvidia I think it
was Nvidia a while back where and when I
say a while back I'm talking like eight
or 10 years or something like that where
it was found that their driver overhead
was greater than amds and so their their
performance ranking was changing the old
the farther back you went like there was
a
similar conversation okay well if you
remember it then it must be eight plus
years ago um and Nvidia went to work and
they they cleaned up their driver and
they they made it less overhead and they
like talked about that over the next
couple of cycles and then it has become
less of a conversation I'm hoping that
that's something that Intel can do I
don't know that for sure but given the
kind of progress that we've seen on
their driver development over the last
couple of years I I have I have some
Faith it's Blind Faith so take it for
what it is but I I I I hope they are
able to do this